for me like I will crush if babban just
takes the [ __ ] phone on Instagram
sign into my stories would be like what
was that meeting about like the rant I
just gave you and you're like yes I can
do that at will it's kind of stupid
I mean it's [ __ ] scary but like I
don't think people realize that [ __ ]
making content is literally like the
sprinkles - my reality of like I do not
believe that anybody that consumes my
content has any true sense that I spend
fifteen hours a day being a CEO of a big
company
[Music]
I was canceled have to get to Cincinnati
for some big meetings tomorrow so got a
jump on private not super fun so how do
you maximize when you're making an
investment you know I hate going fancy
and going private so how am I gonna
maximize I've got five or six teammates
now from Team Gary Vee a couple people I
haven't jammed with as much so trade you
know bringing Sameer new from the paid
team Andy and I need some time but vans
always around so to me one of the
important things to always think about
is when you're put in situations how do
you maximize right people have a flight
cancel dinner like my flights canceled
have you turned that into a meet up with
your fans how do you like schedule some
meetings in the area it's why I have
first in line to have data I might do
random pop-ups how do you go on FaceTime
with your family how do you go on
Instagram live and start a communication
or in scenarios like this how do you
bring your team and basically I'm gonna
have a two-hour meeting right now on our
way to since literally I've taken five
team members we're gonna have a meeting
they're gonna lay go to hotel and fly
back tomorrow while I do my thing the
added expense to what I was already
paying for the private flight with the
extra seats made it ry+ consistently
hack the norms all the action all the
amazing opportunities in today's
environment because of the technology
advances are in the things that have
never been done before making [ __ ] up
try new things not being crippled by
adversity oh [ __ ] all flights Cincinnati
canceled what the hell am I gonna do no
you know finances are an advantage of
mine I can do the private thing but it's
not just that don't be fancy turn it
into a two-hour meeting maximize every
second every opportunity I did that when
I had four bucks I do it now and I can
go private never deviating from the
truth which is maximizing the [ __ ] out
of every situation regardless of if it's
good or bad
yes
meetings like your big meeting of the
day and kind of do like a daily story
around that yeah I don't think I don't
think we can win on snapchat without it
being first-person I don't think it's a
content distribution channel yeah we
can't get away with snapchat stories the
way we can with Instagram stories like
this is good but it's missing we're just
having a meeting about snapchat itself
and that's a good idea
cuz we're [ __ ] up
so we said snapchats that is taking one
person you're meeting with throughout
that week or that day I'm listening to
you tell that story and they
Davee be currently on youtubes going
three four days behind
we just make Facebook stories the
real-time dailyvee but like for this it
should say a time and we're anyway
[Applause]
bless designed and not like in severely
a lot more where we can do all those
right hooks but these other two needs
what do you mean like this it's cool but
I want to know what time it is and where
you're talking
come what sagging of the day this is
Facebook stories okay
so cool we did like this stuff but I
would say we can kill that completely
there's Facebook stories yeah besides
how are we how is Facebook stories going
it started and then it's going down
because we're sort of just replicating
it and then we do what I would call sea
level version of creative but if we
really push like if you want to see we
de vivir live it's Facebook stories just
trying to think of ways well win if we
can actually push people there but we
never got why I do think a way we can do
that is if if I what is hard for me is
going first-person what is not hard for
me is them putting camera on me
so like we could take this and then
right when you're out the meeting like
what meeting was that or just don't
what's your biggest takeaway from your
meeting
that I'm great with
[Applause]
for me like I will crush if a van just
takes the [ __ ] phone on Instagram
sign into my stories would be like what
was that meeting about like the rant I
just gave you and you're like yes I can
do that
at will it's kind of stupid
I mean it's [ __ ] scary but like I
don't think people realize that [ __ ]
making content is literally like the
sprinkles - my reality of like I do not
believe that anybody that consumes my
content has any true sense that I spend
fifteen hours a day being a CEO of a big
company I I mean I bet you you you
weren't how long have you been a painter
so in the what did you've been with us
now on the team for a month or two yeah
like I bet you it's not the way you
thought it was
so what so teach me what is what are
some of the things that are different
than you thought it was being on that's
yes
let's start with the thing I'm most
fascinated by as somebody that's working
a company for two years and knows that I
put out stuff
it would have it surprised if you know
how I was tell the company like I am the
CEO vaynermedia don't be confused it's
more extreme than you thought right it's
not extreme then I thought it's a lot
more like trust and learn that I thought
like I thought you guys had like a
cadence but every day is different yes
and like that's probably the most
being separate from Boehner yes
what do you think as somebody who knows
my content Spanish you know like new
stuff like what's been the biggest
things that are different than the way
you thought it was I'm nicer than even
now I am a meaner this Punk is like Oh
what is he like and I was like you'd
surprisingly like we're not surprising
to me but like exactly like you you're a
good person we're like all these other
people we are not the reality like you
they're not who they say they are I'm
aware like I emailed you and I was like
dude I need a video for like my high
school and you were like done and I was
like oh I think it all makes sense but I
mean I think we're funny like our right
hooks on really right hooks a lot of is
just put put they created I think it's
just trying to level up the creative
with everything like yeah when we did a
really smart story for Monday to Monday
is the most wipes of Y votes we've
gotten a long time which was the texting
because because it's not a right hook
when it's [ __ ] like here's a cool
playlist do you want to discover new
music I'm paying Boyd a lot of money to
discover new [ __ ] music for you
[ __ ] like seriously like what are we
talking about here so I think look but
by the way I'm pumped like when I hear
that from Sid I'm thrilled because that
means we're playing at such rarefied air
that we're creating scrutiny I mean
think about bran work compared to what I
do
and when with bright hooks I just think
about it more on like sending them off
the platform that's why I don't like I
would rather have one story that gives
the thirteen case white votes versus 12
in a row that all swiping up and they
got one
I understand
we should I don't there's too much
process there I think you should pick
and notify them they won right on the
spot
this way you know like you could send
them somewhere else or to an email or to
some forum
I don't care about that but there's too
much telephone there that causes swirl
and then we're letting people down show
the winners
exciting we're all slightly
why don't we show more of the team why
don't we show Sophie like Congrats Ricky
Thompson Johnny McGee and this and that
like make it more content like human
content let's pick a different team
member each week I each day or whatever
like let's do that
yeah more people's faces more let's keep
building up team garyvee because that's
just an honorable asset
[Music]
be like hey it's so from Team Gary bean
Congrats Ricky Thompson season Magoo and
49 Pam's 263 your books are coming on
the way first in line y'all
all right let's completely switch to
human rough raw shout out tag-team
garyvee put the handles in there boo
son done we're making decisions here so
this is about
it's very subjective time in place I
think one of the things I struggle with
is the quotes like like the cop like one
of the things that I'm most fascinating
at you to right now it's really funny I
think one of the great and this is great
for the blog I think one of the great
massively misunderstood things is how
much copy matters
we're so visual and video right now and
social like we grossly underestimate I
can make every single ad he runs better
if I redid the copy I could readily
believe that
100% right anybody that I get it
honestly I want you to help me more so I
think we're making too much [ __ ] on spec
but the problem is I'm the bottleneck
and so like asking you to like have me
do the like all the perfect quotes and
even when I'm approving I don't think
I'm being the best filter I can be which
is why I really want to build up team
Garry because one of the things that can
be done is all of that can go and then a
lot of it can be like tested in that
environment giving me more data I'm
trying to
I'll tell you this one thing for sure
everybody should be hyper aware up
really for you too most of all if I get
into that moment that I get into once
every three weeks where I just write off
four or five
BSU's or what's happening on Twitter is
the greatest thing that's happened to us
on BSU's I'm more motivated now that I
have real otic I actually think one of
the best right hooks is to continue to
build my Twitter through Instagram
because it's motivating me to do word
tweets which is then giving us proxy to
the best BSU's it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy
so what would I say I think that Calvin
or whoever's doing it right now trying
to pull [ __ ] out of dailyvee is a bad
idea it's probably a big waste of time
I feel like none of it's that good like
I feel like I look at nine and I'm
picking the prettiest of the ugly
ducklings out of context doesn't work
where is what should happen is the
audience should be giving us the quotes
like the comments one day late like no
more watch the video give me quotes new
rule no more you don't like it it
doesn't work we're trying to do it it
doesn't work how should we actually be
promoting
what brother like new episodes that's
why we're trying to do it it's was to
try to them I think if we did it no I
think of 12 quotes I'm getting was the
intent to make BS you said
like NASA micro to push that episode and
to make more BS YouTube oh yeah but like
but that's what I was thinking it
supported component across yeah wise
Kelvin better person to me the way we do
bs used at its best is watch people give
DAPs to something I said in comments
[ __ ] I'd rather people go right now and
look at videos that I did four years ago
look through it see where there was love
given to like oh that was fire make that
clip Twitter sirs
everyone swinging out what's there to
say
what it's on
what's that
so much of what I say is evergreen
that's the crazy suit is like I was like
Anthony waited resurfaced all your life
last year debatable everyone did that
hit like one-tenth the size like last
two
that we just redid everything like
you know what this is man this is the
best like just having downtime to be
creative I think we could do such a
[ __ ] amazing highlight hack tomorrow
like if all new [ __ ] showed up there and
it was like three of them would like
some sort of story to it like if they
all work in unison for one day
like if all three of them we're like
black and it just said number one two
and three and yet no idea what the [ __ ]
it was
what [ __ ] the Patriots - so wait a
minute let's go back into like why
so why don't we make a hardcore hardcore
three-and-a-half minute film
five-and-a-half minute film of like what
I actually do its daily beat
that came out
it's not it's a narrated by me in the
right zone I'll read a half minute rant
of look fine
so let's baby test it like to me
something that starts with the truth
which is
besides everything else the thing I
pride myself in the most is that I'm an
operator 98% of you view me as a
motivational this or that because the
last 18 months I've hit paydirt on
content and social but did you know and
like and then like putting visuals
behind that and then maybe even like
having people on my team and people that
work at Vayner and clients skip in what
Babcock saying the thing that freaks me
out most about Gary is he's actually the
best creative in the house or like used
like like you saying like whoa like like
there's so much we can do like new
person on a team and then you client and
then Claude look here's the thing that
is the truth about me of why I think I'm
super successful
I'm really good at a lot of things
shroo I'm not good at certain things but
I'm really really good at a lot of the
things which is why
I'm an enigma
the best
all right it takes a lot BR in
the other thing is in the top 15
personalities that are winning right now
it's what they do full-time my biggest
truth like I genuinely am grateful and
happy because I have life like it's
simple as [ __ ] it's like I don't know
how to say it like I'm not I'm not I'm
not happy that we're on a private plane
I don't give a [ __ ] face at all I'm
happy that like I get to wake up
tomorrow do [ __ ]
I see Liam this has been hitting me
lately really wish this was my life and
professionally forget about like my
family I wish I was 23
we were sitting here this wasn't a
private plane it was like [ __ ] ghetto
ass thing we ate White Castle all day
and [ __ ] went like climb the [ __ ]
mountain the game I really mean it I'm
really more interested in it
it's more fun and this is not more fun
this is the biggest confusion this is
less fun
more fun is zero
the stuff thank you what
now you can always tell the story when
you flew to Cincinnati
have a good night
[Music]